.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Katar -
Austragungsort der Fussball-WM.
Auch Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
tragen im reichen Wüstenstaat
zum reibungslosen Ablauf
des umstrittenen Turniers bei.
Einige von ihnen
leben schon lange hier.
Rund eine Flugstunde entfernt: Dubai,
offener und schillernder als Katar.
Ein Paradies für Fremde -
wenn man sich an die Regeln hält.
Wir begleiten
fünf Schweizerinnen und Schweizer,
die sich auf das Abenteuer
am Golf eingelassen haben.
Worin liegt der Reiz? Was sind
die Herausforderungen des Alltags?
Fühlen sie sich trotz
des Kulturunterschieds heimisch?
In diesem Einfamilienhaus-Quartier
in Doha
wohnt
die Familie von Coralie Durussel.
Töchterchen Aya ist erst
vor wenigen Wochen zur Welt gekommen.
Die gebürtige Westschweizerin
geniesst die letzten Tage
ihres Mutterschaftsurlaubs
und die Unterstützung von Nanny Alma.
* Sanfte Musik *
Den Alltag mit zwei kleinen Kindern
hat sich die 33-Jährige
weniger anstrengend vorgestellt.
Willkommen in Noahs Arche.
Die eine füttere ich gerade.
Mit denen hier spiele ich.
Gleichzeitig passe ich
auf den Kleinen dort auf.
Für Coralies
zweijährigen Sohn Abdulrahman
gibt es nichts Aufregenderes
als den Disney-Film "Lion King".
"Der König der Löwen"
schaut er in Dauerschleife.
Vier- oder fünfmal am Tag.
Es ist verrückt!
Selbst Coralies Ehemann Saeed
schafft es kaum,
die Aufmerksamkeit seines Sohnes
zu gewinnen.
Er arbeitet bei der Militärpolizei,
doch seine Leidenschaft
gilt dem Sport.
Saeed
fährt professionell Motorradrennen
und gilt als bester Fahrer
der Golfregion.
Coralie und die Kinder wollen ihn
später an der Rennstrecke besuchen,
mit Nanny Alma selbstverständlich.
Das ist wirklich Luxus,
was wir hier haben.
Wenn wir in der Schweiz wären,
hätten wir das nicht.
Vielleicht ein Au-pair-Mädchen.
Ich habe grosses Glück.
Wir werden noch
eine zweite Haushälterin haben,
die Alma unterstützt,
weil natürlich ...
Yeah! Ui!
Thank you.
Coralie kam bereits als kleines Kind
mit ihrer Mutter nach Katar.
Arabisch spricht sie fliessend,
auch mit ihren Kindern.
Thank you.
Ich trage sie aus Respekt vor der
Kultur, aber auch für meinen Mann.
2013 konvertierte sie zum Islam.
Verlässt sie das Haus,
trägt sie die Abaya,
das traditionelle Gewand.
Früher habe ich sie während
des Fastenmonats Ramadan getragen.
Eines Tages
hat mich mein Mann dann gefragt,
ob ich die Abaya
nicht immer anziehen könne -
wenigstens bei der Arbeit.
Ich habe Ja gesagt.
Aber als ich die Abaya
dann bei der Arbeit getragen habe,
jedoch nicht in meiner Freizeit,
wurden mir Fragen gestellt.
Daher habe ich angefangen,
sie immer zu tragen.
Tradition ist in Katar wichtig,
obwohl oder gerade weil das Land
einen gewaltigen strukturellen
Umbruch erlebt.
Wo sich heute
Autobahnen durch die Stadt ziehen,
erstreckte sich
noch vor wenigen Jahren die Wüste.
Wenn ich hier fahren würde
wie in der Schweiz,
käme ich nirgends hin, denn es gibt
hier keine wirklichen Regeln.
In diesem Sinne
bin ich ein Motorhead.
Oft fahre ich viel schneller,
als ich darf.
Ich denke, ich habe es im Blut.
Und ich bin ja mit einem
Motorradrennfahrer verheiratet.
Mit dem Auto
fahre ich viel schneller als er.
Motorsport ist nur eine Sportart, mit
der Katar auf sich aufmerksam macht.
Das Emirat gilt als sportbegeistert.
Und die Ausrichtung grosser Events
wie der WM
dient natürlich auch
einer positiven Aussendarstellung.
Es ist Winter.
Schwierige Bedingungen -
nicht nur für die Rennfahrer.
Immer wieder! Siehst du das?
Ich setze das Kopftuch auf,
es fliegt ständig weg
und ich muss es
immer wieder neu richten.
Deshalb habe ich meinem Mann gesagt:
"Das Kopftuch
trage ich nicht immer."
Und es war okay für ihn.
Kleine Kompromisse,
die dazu beitragen,
dass das grosse Ganze funktioniert.
6 Uhr in Dubai.
Im Stadtteil The Springs
werkelt Andrea Hirschi
bereits in der Küche.
Andrea kam vor knapp drei Jahren
mit ihrer Familie nach Dubai.
Erst war es für die
selbstständige Coiffeuse schwierig,
hier Fuss zu fassen, weil sie ihr
Geschäft in Bern weiterführen wollte.
Doch mittlerweile
hat sich alles eingespielt.
Das ist ein Unterschied zur Schweiz,
wo man zum Essen nach Hause geht.
Die Kinder
bleiben hier in der Schule,
was für uns Eltern
etwas vom Besten ist.
Dieser Unterbruch in der Schweiz,
also die Mittagsstunde,
bedeutet für alle nur Stress.
Tochter Sophie geht in die 1. Klasse
einer internationalen Schule.
Für die Sechsjährige
ist heute der erste Schultag
nach einem längeren Corona-Lockdown.
Seit einem halben Jahr
lebt und arbeitet Nanny Cecille
bei den Hirschis.
Wir als Schweizer
haben das ja nicht.
Zu Beginn hatten wir das
auch lange nicht, da wir dachten:
"Das brauchen wir doch nicht."
Aber andererseits unterstützten wir
so ihre Familie in den Philippinen.
Sie kann dafür
ihre fünf Kinder ernähren.
Und so gesehen ...
Sie ist wirklich
eine supergute Seele.
Cecille ist super.
Besonders für Sophie spielt Cecille
eine wichtige Rolle im Alltag.
Eine Beziehung auf Zeit,
denn eigentlich
ist der Arbeitsvertrag von Vater Remo
auf drei Jahre begrenzt.
Der Gebäudetechniker
arbeitet als Projektleiter
für ein Schweizer Sanitärunternehmen.
Das Angebot, nach Dubai zu gehen,
war nicht nur finanziell reizvoll.
Remo geniesst einen ganz neuen Luxus.
Oft sitzen wir
morgens zusammen am Tisch.
Und das ist eigentlich
eine neue Qualität.
Das hatten wir früher nicht.
Früher sass ich um diese Zeit
im Zug Richtung Zürich.
Aber der Schulrun und so -
das ist Andreas Teil.
Remo hat seinen Vertrag
bereits um ein Jahr verlängert.
Ob es dann
zurück in die Schweiz geht,
darüber ist sich das Paar
noch nicht einig.
Einen schönen Tag. Bis später.
- Tschüss.
Gehen wir? Tschüss.
- Tschau.
Komm!
Fast drei Monate lang konnte Sophie
wegen des Lockdowns
nicht in die Schule gehen.
Diese kostet 1'000 Fr. pro Monat.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Auf wen freust du dich am meisten,
Sophie?
Auf meine Freunde.
- Auf deine Freunde?
Nicht immer verläuft die Fahrt
zur Schule so reibungslos.
Heute haben wir
sehr gute Bedingungen.
Keine hupenden Autos.
Niemanden,
der in einer Schlange steht.
In Dubai ist Schule sowohl für Expats
wie auch einheimische Kinder Pflicht.
Die meisten Schulen orientieren sich
am britischen System.
Doch wegen Covid weiss Andrea
eigentlich immer noch nicht so genau,
was Sophie den ganzen Tag hier macht.
Ich konnte noch nie
mit ihr hineingehen.
Ich fahre einfach hin,
bringe sie zur Tür und das ist es.
Dann muss sie reingehen.
Es ist schon sehr hart,
wenn man nicht weiss,
wohin das Kind eigentlich geht
und wie seine Klasse aussieht.
Das wäre eigentlich normal.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich z.B.
konnte zu Fuss zur Schule gehen.
Unsere Schule
war vielleicht 150 m entfernt.
Der Weg führte übers Feld.
Ich durfte über ein Feld gehen und
hatte eine schöne, freie Kindheit.
Das ist auch ein Nachteil, dass sie
nicht allein zur Schule gehen kann.
* Sanfte Musik *
Hier drüben wohnen die ganz Reichen.
Das ist Emirates Hills.
Das sind alles Gastarbeiter,
die hier anstehen, um reinzukommen.
Es sind auch Gärtner,
die dorthin gefahren werden.
Da werden Häuser umgebaut.
Eine
wirklich sehr schöne Wohngegend.
Aber man kommt fast nicht rein.
Zurück nach Katar: traditionell-
muslimisch, wirtschaftlich innovativ.
Das Emirat spielt eine
ganz eigene Rolle in der Golfregion
und wurde noch bis vor zwei Jahren
von den Nachbarstaaten boykottiert.
Das eigene Erdöl und Gas
machten den Wüstenstaat
innerhalb weniger Jahrzehnte zu
einem der reichsten Länder der Welt.
Mit der Ausrichtung der Fussball-WM
will Katar endgültig
zu einem Global Player werden.
Eine dieser neuen Villen hat
Chris Franzen erst kürzlich bezogen.
Mit seiner Frau Rachel und
den beiden Kindern Ashley und Alex.
Umzüge sind sie gewohnt.
Die vier haben schon im Oman,
in Dubai und in Indien gelebt.
Von dort kommt auch
das soeben eingetroffene Stück.
Nimm das mal weg hier!
Nun wird die Familie
eine Weile in Katar leben.
Vater Chris leitet hier bald
ein Fünfsterne-Hotel.
Ein Hotel ist ein Hotel - egal, wo.
Du hast dieselben Probleme.
Du hast dieselben Vor-
und Nachteile.
Für mich ist es weniger ein Problem
als für die Familie.
Ashley hat keine Probleme,
in neue Länder zu gehen.
Aber er hat mir
schon einige Male gesagt,
er würde gerne an einem Ort wohnen
und nicht immer herumreisen.
Aktuell gibt es ein anderes Problem:
Im Haus riecht es.
Offenbar zog eine Maus mit ein.
Ich fütterte die Maus,
als sie hier war.
Irgendwas stinkt. Es stinkt nach
Haschisch seit zwei, drei Wochen.
Seit zwei, drei Wochen.
Ich habe nichts geraucht.
Es ist Wochenende.
Für den gebürtigen Zermatter
eine gute Gelegenheit,
Ashley die Hotel-Baustelle zu zeigen.
Links siehst du das Hotel,
das ich eröffnen werde.
Es sieht doch fantastisch aus.
Sieh dir das mal an.
Einen dreistelligen Millionenbetrag
investiert der katarische Besitzer
in den Bau.
Die genaue Summe bleibt geheim.
Dort, wo der Sandhaufen ist,
wird der Surfpool sein.
Du wirst dort rechts
einen Wasserpark für Kinder haben.
180 m Beach.
Und dort rechts oben
ist die Royal Suite.
Auf zwei Stockwerken verteilt.
Das sind 429 Zimmer.
Yeah.
Oh, cool!
Die Modernisierung Dohas wäre
ohne den Einsatz vieler Gastarbeiter
gar nicht möglich.
Nur gerade 300'000 der knapp 3 Mio.
Einwohner haben einen Katari-Pass.
All okay?
Chris' Hotel dient während der WM
als Unterkunft für wichtige Gäste.
Alles muss rechtzeitig fertig werden.
Ein eigenes Schild. Picobello.
Die Arbeitsbedingungen auf
den Baustellen gaben viel zu reden.
Die grosse Hitze, die Unterbringung,
die Abhängigkeit von Arbeitgebern
und Vermittlungsagenturen
waren und sind die Hauptkritikpunkte.
Wir als Firma ...
... nehmen das sehr ernst,
auch wenn wir Leute einstellen.
Du hörst immer wieder
von diesem Menschenhandel usw.
Wir schauen wirklich, dass die Leute
nichts dafür bezahlen müssen,
um hier zu arbeiten.
Damit fängt es schon an.
Wir stellen sicher,
dass in einem Zimmer
nur eine gewisse Anzahl
Angestellte sind.
Es dürfen pro Zimmer nicht mehr
als zwei Angestellte sein.
Das Büro des Chefs -
momentan noch ein Baucontainer.
Hier lagern auch ein paar Möbel,
die für die Ausstattung des Hotels
zur Auswahl stehen.
No, this table ...
Cool!
Excellent. Let's go!
Ein Job mit viel Verantwortung.
Bis zur Eröffnung in neun Monaten
ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit.
In Basel
plant Gewerkschafterin Rita Schiavi
derweil ihren nächsten Trip
in die Golfregion.
Seit 2018 inspiziert sie in Katar mit
der internationalen Gewerkschaft BHI
regelmässig
die Baustellen der WM-Stadien.
Also die Bauarbeiter sind ja
fast auf der ganzen Welt Migranten.
Und ich bin ja ein Kind
von Migranten.
Ich glaube, ich bin auch deshalb
bei der Baugewerkschaft gelandet.
In Katar ist es extrem.
Dort bzw. am Golf sind eigentlich
alle, die arbeiten, Migranten.
Die Gewerkschafter
kennen die Situation vor Ort
und haben auf den Stadion-Baustellen
schon einiges zur Verbesserung
der Situation beigetragen.
Bei aller berechtigten Kritik
vermisst Rita in den Medien manchmal
einen differenzierteren Blick.
Der Auslöser war ja
dieser "The Guardian"-Artikel.
Er spricht
von 6'500 toten Arbeitern.
Wenn man ihn genau liest, sieht man,
dass es 6'500 in zehn Jahren sind.
Aber es wird
der Eindruck vermittelt,
sie seien alle
auf diesen WM-Baustellen gestorben.
Das stimmt
natürlich überhaupt nicht.
Wir wissen genau,
wie viele in den Stadionbaustellen
wegen Arbeitsunfällen
gestorben sind.
Es waren drei
in den letzten fünf Jahren.
Natürlich
ist jeder Einzelne einer zu viel.
Aber die Quote ist tiefer
als bei uns in der Schweiz.
Eigentlich hätten gerade wieder
Inspektionen stattfinden sollen.
Doch wegen Covid
wurde die Reise abgesagt.
So bald wie möglich
will sie aber wieder hin.
Ritas grosses Ziel ist es, die
Fortschritte auf den WM-Baustellen
für alle Arbeiter und Arbeiterinnen
in Katar durchzusetzen.
Das Problem ist: Der Standard
auf den Stadionbaustellen
ist heute zwar gut,
aber die meisten Bauarbeiter
in Katar arbeiten nicht dort,
sondern
auf allen anderen Baustellen.
Und das sind immerhin
fast 1 Mio. Bauarbeiter.
Katar erlebt, was Nachbar Dubai
schon lange hinter sich hat.
Hier entstand seit den 1990er-Jahren
ein baulicher Superlativ
nach dem anderen.
Dubai ist heute ein Eldorado
für risikofreudige Unternehmer.
Einer von ihnen:
der Tessiner Matteo Boffa.
Dubai ist nicht nur
eine Metropole in der Wüste,
sondern für mich auch
eine Oase der Möglichkeiten.
Aus der Schweiz in eine neue Welt,
in eine arabische Welt zu kommen,
scheint schwierig, aber es ist
ein wirklich grossartiger Schatz.
Matteo arbeitete in der Schweiz
zehn Jahre lang als Banker.
Dann zwang ihn das Schicksal,
noch einmal ganz neu anzufangen.
Die Gründe,
warum ich nach Dubai gezogen bin,
sind eine Mischung aus etwas Gutem
und etwas Schlechtem.
Zum Negativen
gehört sicher meine Scheidung.
In derselben Zeit
habe ich auch meine Mutter verloren.
Das hat mich
in ein schwarzes Loch gezogen
und von meiner Familie entfernt.
Ich habe die Möglichkeit bekommen,
hierherzukommen,
um sechs Monate lang
bei einer Firma zu arbeiten.
Danach habe ich gekündigt und mein
Abenteuer als Unternehmer begonnen.
Der Neustart in Dubai
glückte dem 31-Jährigen auch privat.
Im Wohnzimmer
arbeitet Matteos neue Ehefrau Megan.
Wegen Covid
unterrichtet die südafrikanische
Lehrerin aus dem Homeoffice.
Wegen Covid musste das Paar auch
die grosse Hochzeitsfeier absagen,
die erstmals ihre Familien
hätte zusammenführen sollen.
Doch Matteo macht das Beste draus.
Es ist schön, die Stimme der Kinder
durch den Bildschirm zu hören.
Und ich sehe Megan
schon nicht mehr nur als meine Frau,
sondern auch
als Mutter unserer Kinder.
Das ist ein fantastisches Gefühl.
Ich bin sicher,
dass unsere Zukunft wunderbar wird,
mit einer Mutter wie ihr.
Als Unternehmer hat sich Matteo auf
nachhaltige Start-ups spezialisiert:
finanzieller Erfolg
im Einklang mit der Umwelt.
Sogar das "Forbes Magazine"
berichtete schon über ihn.
Sein bislang grösster Erfolg:
ein spezieller Turnschuh
mit einer speziellen Geschichte.
Diese Geschichte
ist fast schon romantisch.
An der Universität,
an der ich Nachhaltigkeit
und Entrepreneurship unterrichtete,
gab es einen jungen Inder: Ashay.
Und der präsentierte diese Idee:
ein neuer, veganer Schuh,
komplett aus Plastiktüten
und Plastikflaschen hergestellt.
Aber
nicht nur der Schuh ist nachhaltig,
sondern auch der Schuhkarton.
Er enthält Samen,
die Fantastisches erschaffen können,
wenn sie in die Erde gepflanzt
und gewässert werden.
Schau: Aus unserem Schuhkarton
ist dieser Basilikum gewachsen.
10'000 Dollar investierte Matteo
anfangs in das Schuhprojekt.
Inzwischen hat sich
sein Einsatz zigfach rentiert.
Und die Glücksträhne hält an.
Heute haben wir einen Wert
von 10 Mio. Dollar.
Wir sind dabei, weiter zu wachsen,
und haben
weitere Investitionen erhalten.
Daraus kann gar nichts anderes
als eine Erfolgsgeschichte werden.
Katar.
Coralie ist bei ihrem Mann
Saeed auf der Rennstrecke in Doha.
Sohn Abdulrahman fährt schon mal vor.
Stilecht, auf zwei Rädern.
Seit ungefähr anderthalb Wochen
hat er dieses Fahrrad.
Aber ich denke, in einigen Monaten
wird er Motorrad fahren.
Der Losail International Circuit
ist für Coralies Familie fast
wie ein zweites Zuhause geworden.
Saeed ist so etwas
wie der Tom Lüthi der Golfregion.
Während der Rennsaison reist er viel
und muss täglich trainieren.
Dafür wird er von seinem Arbeitgeber,
dem katarischen Militär,
freigestellt.
In den letzten Jahren verdiente Saeed
mit dem Sport nicht nur gutes Geld,
sondern auch
die volle Bewunderung seines Sohnes.
Ich lege es nicht darauf an,
aber wenn er es mag ...
Brumm!
Ein Kuss für den Vater ...
... und einer
für den schützenden Helm.
Rennfahrer leben gefährlich ...
Bange Minuten vergehen ...
Der verunglückte Fahrer ist aus
derselben Box gestartet wie Saeed.
Wir wollen sichergehen,
dass es ihm gut geht.
Normalerweise bringen sie
das Motorrad schnell zurück.
Aber bis jetzt ist es nicht da.
Wir müssen wissen, ob er okay ist.
Falls nicht, müssen wir zum Notarzt.
Alle warten auf Entwarnung.
Weltweit endeten letztes Jahr
vier Motorradunfälle
auf der Rennstrecke tödlich.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Das Motorrad ist hin.
Ein schwerer Moment für Coralie.
Auch Saeed riskiert
als Rennfahrer täglich sein Leben.
Natürlich macht es mir Angst,
das zu sehen.
Aber wir glauben auch
an die göttliche Vorsehung.
Ob nun mit dem Motorrad,
im Auto oder zu Fuss:
Wenn etwas geschehen muss,
wird es eben geschehen.
Dieser Gedanke hilft mir mental.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ich dachte, mit den Kindern
würde er von sich aus aufhören.
Aber das hat er nicht.
Ich will nicht die Person sein,
die ihm sagt: "Hör auf!"
Und ja: So Gott will,
beschützt er ihn.
Natürlich haben sie Angst. Ich
versuche auch, Unfälle zu vermeiden.
Aber man kann auch zu Hause
auf der Toilette verunglücken.
Endlich kommt der verunglückte Fahrer
zurück in die Box. Es geht ihm gut.
* Sanfte Musik *
Anders
als im konservativen Katar üblich
stillt Coralie die kleine Aya
auch in der Öffentlichkeit.
Ja, ich mache mich frei von Tabus.
Ich verstosse gegen die Norm.
Aber, ja, es ist mir egal,
ob es den Leuten passt oder nicht.
Meistens ist für mich alles,
was sie macht, okay.
Aber wenn wir an einem öffentlichen
Ort sind und sie laut loslacht,
muss ich ihr manchmal sagen:
"Beruhige dich."
Ich weiss nicht ...
Cut! Bringt das nicht.
Ein modernes Paar,
das seinen eigenen Weg sucht.
Anders
als das eher traditionelle Katar
inszeniert sich Dubai
gegenüber dem Westen
als Hotspot für Touristen
und innovatives Businessparadies.
Wer sich hier
an die Grundregeln hält,
kann die Strukturen für sich nutzen.
So wie Matteo Boffa.
Meine Arbeit in der Schweiz
hat mir ermöglicht, Geld zu sparen,
das ich hier dann für Investitionen
zur Verfügung hatte.
Dies ist meine Geschichte:
vom Angestellten zum Unternehmer.
In den meisten Fällen
scheiterten die Projekte,
das sage ich ganz ehrlich.
Aber einige dieser Firmen
entwickeln sich gerade
und generieren Gewinne:
Es ist wie eine Lawine.
Hallo, hallo. Hey, guys.
Matteo besucht ein Start-up, an
dem er kürzlich Anteile erworben hat:
ein Fahrservice -
für das eigene Auto.
Die Geschäftsidee
entstand aus der Not heraus.
Einer der Firmengründer wollte sein
Auto in die Garage bringen lassen.
Das war kompliziert und teuer,
deshalb entwickelte er eine App.
Wer nun sein Auto in die Garage
oder nach einer Party sicher
nach Hause bringen lassen möchte,
kann per Klick
einen Fahrservice buchen.
Einer der ersten Kunden war Matteo.
Ich nutzte den Service
und war sofort verliebt:
Jemand anders fuhr mein Auto. Und
auf dem Rückweg habe ich gerechnet:
Wie ist es möglich, dass die Jungs
damit Geld verdienen?
Ich fragte den Fahrer.
Zu der Zeit hattet ihr
nur vier oder fünf Fahrer.
Er gab mir Buntys Nummer.
Ich rief ihn an und sagte:
"Ich möchte alles über euer Business
wissen. Ich möchte mich beteiligen."
Und ein paar Monate später
begann dieses Abenteuer.
100'000 US-Dollar hat Matteo
in seine Firmenanteile investiert.
Im Gegenzug profitieren die
beiden Gründer von Matteos Netzwerk
und seinem Know-how.
Matteo ist wichtig
für unser Unternehmen.
Er war
unser erster grosser Investor.
Er hat einen guten Namen
in der Start-up-Szene.
Wenn er etwas über uns postet,
macht das einen Riesenunterschied.
Man muss immer
die richtigen Ohren erreichen.
Und Matteo ist eine gute Stimme.
Als Matteo Ende 2016 nach Dubai kam,
knüpfte er bereits auf dem Weg vom
Flughafen zum Hotel erste Kontakte.
Eine wichtige Anlaufstelle damals wie
heute: der Swiss Business Council,
eine Art Handelskammer
für Schweizerinnen und Schweizer.
Aktuell leben rund 3'000 in Dubai -
die grösste eidgenössische
Gemeinschaft in der arabischen Welt.
Sechs Jahre nach seiner Ankunft
spielt Matteo
eine wichtige Rolle hier.
Uns gibt es schon seit 25 Jahren.
Alle, die nach Dubai kommen,
kennen niemanden hier.
Sie wissen nicht, was tun,
und wenden sich an uns.
Wir geben Orientierungshilfe
und vermitteln ihnen
eine Art Home-sweet-home-
away-from-home-Gefühl,
wenn ich das
auf Englisch sagen darf,
damit die Schweizer sich auch hier
in der Wüste heimisch fühlen.
Dubai funktioniert
ganz anders als die Schweiz.
In der konstitutionellen Monarchie
liegt alle Macht beim Emir
und seiner Familie.
Ein strenges System,
das man akzeptieren muss,
wenn man Dubai als Lebensmittelpunkt
wählt, findet Matteo.
Dubai gilt als eine der sichersten
Städte der Welt und das liegt daran,
dass es sehr strenge Regeln gibt,
die man befolgen muss.
Aber wenn ich ehrlich bin,
bevorzuge ich ein solches System,
bei dem du genau weisst,
wie weit du gehen kannst.
Hier hat man die Möglichkeit,
in einer Stadt zu leben,
die extrem dynamisch und schnell ist
und in der man ein Business gründen
und von Null auf testen kann.
Trotzdem,
"die Regeln beachten" bedeutet auch:
keine Kritik am System,
keine gleichgeschlechtliche Liebe,
kein Alkohol in der Öffentlichkeit.
Der Islam
ist in Dubai Staatsreligion.
Kultur und Tradition haben -
trotz aller Moderne -
einen hohen Stellenwert.
Andrea Hirschi
besucht oft den lokalen Gewürzmarkt.
Heute benötigt sie Nelken -
für eine Bratensauce.
* Sanfte Musik *
All diese Gewürze und all
dieses Kleine ... Einfach ... Ja.
Ich liebe es.
Man findet immer etwas.
Es ist so inspirierend hier.
Ich könnte alles im Warenhaus
kaufen, aber ich finde ...
Zu Hause gehe ich auch zum Bauern,
um Fleisch oder Gemüse zu holen.
Also gehe ich auch hier zum Bauern,
um die Gewürze zu kaufen.
Ja, und man unterstützt sie halt.
Ich denke nicht,
dass sie hier viel Geld machen.
Aber man unterstützt hier
immer gewisse Lokalitäten.
Trotz der modernen Shoppingmalls
sind die Souks
aus Dubai nicht wegzudenken.
Wer hier
ein gutes Geschäft machen möchte,
sollte allerdings verhandeln können.
Du musst mit dem Mann verhandeln.
Sag ihm, dass du ihm 20 gibst.
Du musst lernen zu verhandeln.
Du solltest nicht das bezahlen,
was sie sagen.
Sag ihm: "Twenty."
Für umgerechnet 8 Fr.
wechselt das Kamel den Besitzer.
Das hier ist der totale Gegensatz
zum anderen Dubai
mit den Wolkenkratzern.
Es erinnert mich so ein bisschen
an unsere Stadt in Bern
mit den ganzen Lauben,
obwohl es zu Bern gegensätzlich ist.
Aber ich fühle mich hier
irgendwie wohl.
Andrea führt,
wie die meisten Expats aus Europa,
ein privilegiertes Leben in Dubai.
Schätzungsweise 70 %
der knapp 3 Mio. Gastarbeiter hier
arbeiten im Niedriglohnsektor.
Wer jedoch, wie Remo,
als ausgebildete Fachkraft
für eine europäische Firma arbeitet,
profitiert vom rasanten Wachstum
in der Golfregion.
In Dubai zahlt man z.B.
keine Steuern. Das kommt noch dazu.
Aber in erster Linie
ist es sicher die Herausforderung,
im Ausland zu sein
und andere Kulturen zu erleben.
Das ist eigentlich das,
was ich immer wollte.
Für mich könnte es
eigentlich noch weitergehen.
Wenn wir kein Kind hätten,
wäre ich sicher auch noch dabei.
Aber jetzt ist Sophie da.
Für mich ist es wichtig, dass sie
irgendwo Wurzeln haben kann.
Wurzeln kannst du nur haben, wenn du
fest in den Boden wachsen kannst.
Und das ist schon ...
Deshalb will ich auch zurückkehren.
Zurück
oder auf ins nächste Abenteuer?
Eine Frage, auf die das Paar
bald eine Antwort finden muss.
In Doha -
bei der Familie von Coralie.
Wegen der Pandemie
und ihres Mutterschaftsurlaubs
war Coralie lange zu Hause.
Schon bald muss sie wieder arbeiten -
eine Veränderung, die alle belastet.
Ich weiss nicht.
Sie war nicht mehr im Büro seit ...
... zwei Jahren.
- Zwei Jahre!
Während sie hier war,
war es grossartig.
Sie hatte so viel Zeit
mit den Kindern.
Coralie arbeitet beim
Supreme Committee, der Staatsstelle,
welche die WM in Katar organisiert.
Ihr Job im Team für internationale
Beziehungen ist stressig.
Früher habe ich immer gesagt:
"Ich werde Mutter sein
und arbeiten - keine Frage."
Wenn man mich jetzt fragt,
würde ich sofort meinen Job aufgeben
und den ganzen Tag
bei den Kindern sein.
Aber aus finanziellen Gründen
machen wir das nicht.
Ich weiss nicht.
Ich freue mich nicht gerade darauf.
Das ist sehr emotional,
nur schon, wenn ich darüber spreche.
Dass Aya noch so klein ist,
macht es schwierig für sie.
Aber das Leben ist nicht billig,
und nur mit Saeeds Gehalt
und den unregelmässigen
Einkünften aus dem Sport
könnte die Familie
ihren Standard nicht halten.
Wir müssen sehen, wie es läuft.
Nun geht sie wieder arbeiten.
Dir wäre es lieber,
ich bliebe zu Hause.
Natürlich.
Aber wie gesagt:
Mit nur einem Einkommen
ist es schwierig.
Aber ich habe ihr angeboten,
dass sie zu Hause bleiben kann.
Stimmt doch?
- Ja, klar.
Aber finanziell ... Wir bauen
ein Haus, und es wäre dumm.
Ja, es ist nicht wirklich leicht.
Andrea hat es geschafft,
ihren Coiffeurladen in Bern
auch von Dubai aus weiterzuführen.
Ein zweites Einkommen zum
steuerfreien Verdienst ihres Mannes.
Anders als sie
erlebt ihre Tochter Sophie
eine Kindheit in Luxus
und finanzieller Sicherheit.
Es ist schon ein Traum.
Manchmal denke ich:
"Wir leben in einem Traum."
Oder:
"Wir leben jetzt unseren Traum."
Ich habe auch immer
ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Warum
können wir das jetzt geniessen?
Wir wuchsen
in ziemlich armen Verhältnissen auf.
Wir hatten nicht sehr viel.
Meine Eltern waren beide jung.
Sie mussten beide arbeiten.
Unsere Grosseltern
waren eigentlich wie unsere Eltern.
Es kommen dann Traditionen:
dieses Leben der Familien
aus den 50er-Jahren.
Da bin ich schon in einem Zwiespalt.
Manchmal denke ich mir:
"Geniesse es halt bewusst, Andrea."
Oder Remo sagt mir immer:
"Denk doch nicht darüber nach,
was die anderen sagen. Es ist egal."
Bedenken, dass Sophie durch die Jahre
in Dubai verwöhnt werden könnte,
hat sie dennoch.
So aufzuwachsen oder das eigene Kind
so aufwachsen zu sehen -
darüber mache ich mir
immer wieder Gedanken.
Darum habe ich auch unserer Nanny
gesagt, dass ich nicht möchte,
dass sie aufräumt. Ich möchte, dass
Sophie aufräumt. Sophie hilft mit.
Das ist immer ein Zwiespalt.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie das in der Schweiz sein wird.
* Sanfte Musik *
Mitte der 1990er-Jahre
öffnete sich Katar gegenüber Reformen
und Modernisierung.
Die Gigantomanie und den
Massentourismus des Nachbarn Dubai
möchte man hier vermeiden.
Der Souk Wakif, Dohas alter Markt,
stammt ursprünglich aus dem 17. Jh.,
einer Zeit, in der die Millionenstadt
noch ein Beduinendorf war.
In dem altehrwürdigen Ambiente
entdeckt Chris plötzlich
seine Vorliebe für Kuriositäten.
* Muezzin-Gesang *
Das ist super. Fast wie in Zermatt,
wo man mit den Kuhglocken aufwacht.
Bis 1971
war Katar britisches Protektorat.
Die einheimische, arabische Küche hat
dies jedoch unbeschadet überstanden.
Gemeinsam Zeit zu verbringen,
kommt für Chris und seine Familie
im Alltag oft zu kurz.
What are you having for dinner?
Let's just order some taboulé,
some hummus ...
Obwohl ihm der Druck im Nacken sitzt,
sein Hotel rechtzeitig zu eröffnen,
hat diese Vorbereitungsphase
auch Vorteile.
Sobald das Hotel offen ist
und ich wieder voll arbeite,
ist es sehr selten,
dass wir zusammen essen.
Darum geniesse ich gerade diese Zeit
der Hotel-Voreröffnung schon.
Der gelernte Koch mag das Essen hier.
Das ist
sicher nichts für Vegetarier.
Aber es ist typisch arabisch:
Es wird immer viel zu viel serviert.
Wenn es dunkel ist, erwacht das Leben
auf dem alten Markt.
Türkisches Eis
wird auf magische Weise serviert.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
An der Marina von Dubai.
Matteo und Megan
sind erst standesamtlich verheiratet.
Diese Tage hätte die grosse
Familienfeier stattfinden sollen.
Endlich hätten sich
die beiden Familien kennengelernt.
Wegen Corona fiel alles ins Wasser.
So, cheers.
Wir dachten, Dubai sei der perfekte
Ort für unsere Hochzeitsfeier.
Die Schweiz und Südafrika
sind zwölf Flugstunden entfernt,
aber nach Dubai
sind es aus der Schweiz nur 6 Std.
und aus Südafrika 8 1/2 Std.
Logistisch war die Idee grossartig
und die Enttäuschung
natürlich umso grösser.
Es ist ein grosser Traum für ein
Mädchen: das Kleid, deine Familie,
die mit dir feiert, dass du die
Liebe deines Lebens gefunden hast.
Der erste Tanz mit meinem Vater -
darauf hatte ich mich
wirklich gefreut.
Und zu wissen,
dass das nicht passieren würde,
war sehr traurig und enttäuschend.
Dass Matteos verstorbene Mutter Megan
nicht mehr kennenlernen kann,
erfüllt Matteo mit Wehmut.
Doch auch mit den beiden Vätern
hatte er sich auf
einen besonderen Moment gefreut.
Das Wichtigste für mich
wäre gewesen, meine beiden Väter,
den aus der Schweiz
und den aus Südafrika,
hier auf einen Brandy und einen Wein
zu treffen und gemeinsam zu feiern.
Das war mein Traum.
Und dabei "Sweet Caroline"
zu singen.
Das ist unser Lied.
Aber wir holen das nach.
Und es wird noch besser sein,
als wir es uns vorgestellt haben.
Ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
In der nächsten Folge:
Coralie Durussel zurück im Job.
Die Fussball-WM rückt näher.
Stress pur für die zweifache Mutter.
Ausserdem: Rita Schiavi in Katar.
Die Gewerkschafterin
überprüft die Arbeitsbedingungen
auf den WM-Baustellen.
Und: Matteo Boffa auf Stippvisite
bei einem seiner Geschäftspartner.
Aus altem Plastik
werden neue Taschen:
Upcycling als Erfolgsrezept.